[Musica]
ci siamo
let's go quindi bisogna farsi fuori ma
devo scappare no ma deve andare dritto
ti si forma lascia dietro più che altro
ovviamente non puoi sbattere nella tua
stessa scia si è tipo non c'è o se non
ci credono ma dai
dalla mappa ci sono dei poteri che li
prendi ti danno delle abilità speciali
vieni faccia attenzione a mio zio
[Applauso]
l'impasto addestrative delle vite
mio zio mentre toglieva la radio ho
dovuto fare una curva alla fine sono
finiti va bene ci sono
nella mappa più fidati abbia mai visto
fino adesso il piemonte è veramente
incredibile ma adesso ti passerà appena
ti raggiungo chigi
eccolo ti taglio la strada no non ci
credo se da volkel tattica era è la
tattica del battere contro il muro per
disorientare gli avversari non dovuti
mai allora adesso faccio un potere che
non mi aspettavo dai come mai
com'è possibile pagarle che guerra
qualcuno attivato qualche cosa c'è ke ti
fa andare tutti lei non ci credo ma come
hai fatto a saltare ha schiantato sul
sul palazzo per poi saltare al procedure
il potere questa volta è stato
incredibile se siete viale volta è un po
problematico per ma siamo tipo tipo i
power ranger lavandaie l'ha provata è
niente fare da cioccolato prezzo il
tentativo non è vero cosa per
l'acceleratore è un po si liberino
questo giorno fa infatti non è vero
quasi preso no ragazzi
no non è vero non è vero
ma non ci credo mentre guardavo fair e
mi hai ucciso dai non lo state già
prendendo ti giuro
cosa è successo sei morto no aveva
sbattuto vicenda ma ti prego
ma come mai ma non muori mai vedi che
mamma mia altezza al vantaggio non so
come ho fatto nella vita arzo salvo
demorde entrambi io non li ho vinti già
guarda io guarda io non ho parole per
descrivere me stesso voglio avere perché
[Musica]
ma cosa sta succedendo l'ha preso le
morse 3 manca e 321 siamo l'attenzione
per è messa male
si no queste mamma mia opinione credo è
sì neanch'io volontà ci credo sono sanno
220 ma maria che battaglia raga che
battaglia finita per me è praticamente
non ne ho più di vite ma stamperà
giocando il tutto per niente va via e
per la via manca stefan una vita sola
teoricamente dai
[Musica]
perché basta non offre non ci credo ma
credo non ci credo non ci credo 11 un
bel vantaggio devo sfruttarla
no ci ho vinto no ma anche a una vita
hai una vita che te la conta come quel
come da zero se l'avrei mai detto quindi
non ti lamentare
ok ti giuro che se perdo anche quando
hai 0 vite io me ne vado c'è una volta
che sei a zero devo devi comunque essere
lì per vincere ti pare anche perché io
ero morto lì e non sapevo dove andare
troppo per quello dover entrare da
chiuderti la strada e non ho pensato che
io dovevo camminare ad una strada 10
questo gioco gigi gigi che bei ragazzi
ma sembra molto più rubata la faccenda
però vabbè dove siete importante fare
fuori step poi c'era ma perché ogni
volta vinci tu nelle cose cioè non è
possibile non vieni qua dove metti la ma
che le pene sono io e sono rosa io
abbiamo capito anche ma tu colori sono
rosse ma come è figurati sara come se
fosse la mia scia io sono rosa magari
anche amati colori e sono sia la roma ad
abituarmi vieni 6 coraggio dove siete
no cielo sia differente mamma mia chiesa
al vantaggio sulla sua figlia
ma l'altro signorino sono qua amico mio
vieni tu quando vuoi ti aspetto forse
anche per la mia ti prego ti prego io da
molti come il salto no sono nato
lentissimo
ebbene il senatore ragazzo chiamato
ancora nove vite stai ma ancora non sei
morto solo una volta
io sono morto sai com'è possibile come
hai fatto con quanta convinzione volte
guerra maledetto infame sono riuscito
attenzione ska combattono lo hanno
chiosato il coso stato io ti sto
puntando ma non è sereno e non potevo
girare perché c'era la sua scia
maledetta lo sai quello che rallenta il
tempo è un perche per tutti si può
infatti nera molto se non ha molto senso
se riesco a togliermi preda davanti che
mi chiude ti prego ma che forse
sollecito in una maniera stranissima
sono riuscito ho fatto non ho va beh ma
io non dovevo rivedere questo avevo
fatto una roba incredibile
insomma non sei morto non sei morto
mio dio non ci mamma mia ragazzi mamma
cosa sta succedendo ho fatto delle robe
non so neanche io cosa ho fatto e
proponi verdetto è molto divertente fare
morire perché a morire sono stati ancora
ma ti rendi conto di come ti sei salvata
ti rendi conto
va bene e più eclatante il tuo
salvataggio
ero convintissimo tutti morti ma anche
io per non fare questa cosa e non fare
non ci credo non mi sono salvato di
nuovo non so cosa volete
era un'idea come sta succedendo lì mi
sto vedendo europee ma dai market e
tutti e 23 i miei recuperato 344 mamma
mia ragazzi perché poi non è molto
versatile stato quando cadi una marca
guarda te lo meriti che james bond james
bond
ho visto cose alle mani
il prendersi è il tuo momento stessi
proprio loro che è ma devo aspettare di
esaltanti non ho capito ho capito cosa
voglia di fare ma non sono riuscito a
saltare 2 2 ma effetto perfetto era la
mia scia quella non hai saltato anche da
bere non proprio
mammamia più soltanto adesso no ragazzi
io non ho mai giocato alta così fig ha
salvato perché già al 1 c'è il muro
c'era il muro un muro c'era ho preso
quello muro
mio dio ma è solo piena vita hai solo
per una vita due rischio per snes
detenzione combattutissima amico mio non
mi morire a caso perché ti devo fare
fuori io a v hai capito io voglio la
vittoria così mi devo impegnare così e
levi mule di franco levi voleva uccidere
abitative nella schiatta se no ti prego
no ti prego melo fare non lo fare ti
prego non l'ho preso turbo la fine mette
sempre ha sempre una mamma ma come non è
vero e ti prego ti magia di morire ce
l'avevi presa tutta la vivono a parole
ha pagato il gioco fair e non hai capito
io lo guardo incredibile ma contro il
muro
hai paura ho paura sì però anche io devo
combattere un mi manca un minuto vero
che proprio al massimo dell'ansia
proprio rischio le sanno e nessuno l'ha
rischiata la mamma mia
nasce da una migliore proprio loro credo
che è partita incredibile che mappa che
video è quindi ragazzi si conclude qui
la nostra partita su gta la nostra sfida
è incredibile contro steve fair e ho
vinto io tutte e due
mi sembra incredibile in realtà non ho
idea di come io abbia fa non lo so non
mi che non lo so scrivete i ragazzi al
canale anche quello di sempre che la
shin d'estinzione se volete supportarmi
su forniture
come sempre lo trovate qui che lo
trovate qui
fatelo perché così escono tanti video
belli visto che sono supportati da ci
rivediamo come sempre un prossimo video
video godere questi cori ma una volta
tanto bella ragazzi
[Musica]